this is uh yeah this is a warm up so
anyone can play
but then starting in about 50 minutes
there will be the actual title arena
okay stafford gambit time
queen d6 is a move i've studied this at
some point
it's a fun kind of fishing pole idea
i'm guessing 1600 oh 2100
that was nice a stafford gambit is so
so dangerous especially in bullets
because it's so easy to like fall victim
to
these these sort of attacks
the pawn is pinned
all right let's play e5 this game so
staff for gamba time
yeah i had this position earlier it's a
fun line earlier my opponent played g3
and got mated
wow
deja vu how many people have fallen into
this
only chess as deja vu
36 times yeah this is the second game
today
ending exactly the same same variation
let's do um 30 seconds
i could probably do the command myself
what was qh5 come on chat
chat can do better
okay chat you should try it as as hard
as possible
let's play okay i know what to play
against chat
oh but does chat know what to play
against me
maybe what i could do i could have an
auto mod setting
to like just block any any mention of
king e2
that would be the most cruel
king two has six okay so there's six
trolls in the chat
knight f3 okay play knight f6
and do some copycats or copy chats
every move there's king e2 no don't
don't don't let king e2 win
yeah knight takes e5
i just want to play with stafford gambit
i feel like knight takes e5 barely won
there
oh chat's in slow mo now ah
whoa chad's in 120 seconds slow mode no
oh slow-mo is off okay
there there goes chad again
okay so this will be really interesting
what what will twitch shot play in
stafford gambit
stafford gambit accepted i feel like
this is going to be more difficult
because they learned their lesson from
the previous game
um this is also interesting to see like
what the most common moves
it's kind of like it just reminds me of
having an opening database
where we can see which moves will be
most likely to be to be played
i'm a little bit nervous
so far chat's playing like a gm but that
was the case last game and then you you
delayed bon cloud
so we have bishop e2 we have h3
bishop bishop g5 bishop g5 come on just
be active
be active do it bishop g5
okay i'm going for my
beloved attack
i i had this position a few times
earlier today
um a lot of people oh people don't know
how to castle that's funny
i think you have to type 0-0
a lot of people typing oh that show
yeah you can't vote for me you can only
vote for white
h3 is a good move i'm pretty sure it's
0-0 right
is it
i guess people people are figuring it
out
wow everyone wants a castle
one vote for king d2 because king e2 is
illegal
okay wow so many votes for castling okay
time to be aggressive be careful
be careful chat i'll help you out a
little bit
be careful what does that say c4
that says c4 a lot of the moves being
suggested
hangmate
this is so funny
this is really funny
okay wow
i can't believe this
especially like i'm playing against
my own twitch chat and you should have
been watching earlier today i had this
position
twice earlier today and
and both of my opponents earlier today
played g3
it was in the title arena and the title
warm-up arena
and twitch and twitch chat saying falls
for the same thing
it's so funny oh can can chat resign
can you vote for resigning king each one
only legal move
because apparently resigning is not a
legal move
do i torture chat
don't get mad at me i just want to win a
pawn
oh offer draw can i
do i offer draw when i have made in one
whoa it's five dollars from mr hi are
you able to say the alphabet backwards
try start from p tab
ah that's alphabet backwards right
oh two people voted for king ji won
everyone else trying to okay i'll offer
a draw and see what happens
oh never mind checkmate okay i offer to
draw
but you guys didn't accept soon enough
yeah this is a fun fun little trap
but actually this is so this bishop um
actually d3 bishop e2 h3
it's one of the best ways to meet the
stafford
should have gone kd to smh
king d2 probably in hindsight would have
allowed
white to survive longer
but in this position there's only one
move which keeps quite alive
um because yeah this threat is so
menacing
if white takes so if white takes with a
pawn
it's this is force mate i believe
yeah this is just force mates like white
can delay it
but um yeah the only move here
which doesn't lose is e5 not the easiest
move to find
f4 doesn't work because that's illegal
um that's it's pinned by the bishop
so the point of e5 is that after queen
takes e5
then white can play bishop takes g4
and the threat is rookie one so
after takes rookie one wins the queen
and if e5 were played i would have taken
with knight
and the game would continue
oh yeah bishop takes his um is probably
the second best move
yeah we can see it's it's losing but
the problem with bishop takes is the
attack is raging
and yeah e5 here queen g6
this is all fun for black
so anyway that's probably youtube worthy
well i might do i might compile
the two games from earlier today along
with this game
try and show that chat needs to
to learn their lesson based on the games
i play
but that was a fun game um in general
next time
play something like c3 yeah preparing d4
and then i mean this is one of probably
a few refutations
to uh the stafford gambit
oh finney finney says don't make fun of
us
okay i won't make fun of you but maybe
people in the youtube comments will make
fun of you
or maybe you're the same people so you
can make fun of yourself